rose de son nom de scène à 22 ans elle
est auteur compositeur interprète mais
aussi étudiante en lettres modernes elle
a commencé la musique au début de son
adolescence comme un échappatoire à une
famille qui ne la rendait pas heureuse
chez moi une fille ça se marie très tôt
et on ne manque pas forcément son avis
sur la politique sur les études sur sa
façon de s'habiller et pour moi la
musique c'était le seul ou même
l'écriture des paroles c'est le seul
moyen d'écrire ce que je voulais sans
m'en prendre une
donc j'ai trouvé ça génial je dirige et
quand vous êtes face à une feuille
blanche pouvait raturé vous pouvez
écrire vous êtes à maîtresse de la
feuille blanche et moi mais c'est
tranquille quand je faisais ça à ses 18
ans elle a quitté sa ville natale
strasbourg pour étudier dans les
yvelines
c'est ici qu'elle s'est engagé davantage
dans la musique quand je suis arrivé ici
je préfère tout et n'importe quoi mais
j'étais vraiment vraiment tout seul
c'était la jungle mais c'était la
première fois que je que je me sente
heureuse en fait j'ai fait des fêtes de
la musique j'ai participé à des concours
j'ai fait des balles j'ai aussi déjà
inscrits pour chanter c'était dans un
petit village la moyenne d'âge était 65
ans mais c'était génial
rose ne se cantonne pas qu'à un style
ses influences viennent du brésil de la
russie ou encore de la chine elle va
bientôt sortir un ep après cette année
difficile d'un point de vue musical et
bien vous mettez pose surtout alors que
il ya une certaine frustration qui monte
il ya des gens qui vous appelle et qui
vous disent final je te lâches et puis
ben watt vous recommencez toulepleu
début vous avez envie de pleurer
mais là ça va mieux depuis depuis un
mois ça va beaucoup mieux ça reprend du
projet mon projet à moi sera bientôt
terminée donc en attendant de rejoindre
peut-être un label ou une maison de
disques elle appelle tous les jours dans
la salle de concert de l'université
versailles saint quentin
elle se produira pour la fête de la
musique le 19 juin à maurepas et le 21
juin à saint rémy les chevreuse